what's going on people today myself
shonen and vocal pineapple are about to
explain some of our top predictions for
the final act of mikey academia
all right so before we fully get into
the predictions i just wanted to ask
both of you how you think this final axe
compares to the beginnings of the war
arc from a couple years ago because you
know as we've seen there are a ton of
similarities between the two storylines
especially with the heroes being split
up and you know one group trying to
contain shigeraki i feel like this arc
is is really good compared to the last
arc or the the last work even though i
feel like there's aspects of the last
war that had me more hype right like the
whole mirko situation and the high ends
and all that stuff there was a little
more tension for me to be honest but i
feel like horikoshi is building towards
like having a big climax sort of where a
lot of different things are happening
that are going wrong for the heroes you
have the whole dobby situation with the
light in his chest toga's doing uh the
sad man's parade probably right uh all
for one is rewinded shigaraki were
probably gonna leave him off on a
cliffhanger so it seems like we're gonna
get to that point soon where it's like
oh god this is so much worse than last
arc than what you guys were going
through what are you gonna do
i think that this arc at least is
suffering with like i don't i don't know
if it's a majority of the fandom but
i'll say that at least a vocal portion
of it is definitely against this arc for
the most part i mean you know it very it
goes in peaks and valleys like one week
something hype will happen then
everybody's like oh this is great and
then the next three weeks it'll kind of
just be mild and then it's like oh this
is mid hero academia that's like
you know i get it the first arc had like
the whole um
novelty to it because it hadn't really
happened before and we were waiting for
all these storylines to converge and
everything and all of these matchups
that people that we were waiting for to
happen finally happened and now that
it's just kind of happening again yeah
and and the difference in time between
the last walk in this world it wasn't
that much time between them was it like
not much building back-to-back yeah
um even this you know the thing that got
me most interested with the current arc
the afo rewinding himself kind of thing
i love it but it feels like it comes out
of nowhere because i'm like what's
happened when did this get set up yeah
it's really confusing i don't know how
it happened i'm happy that it's
happening but i don't know how i think
the only thing that it could potentially
be is that they had
bullets right like they had them for a
while enough that ujico could kind of
remake them so maybe there was some sort
of you know thing that they did or but
then how did all for one get any of that
right like uchi was arrested the lab was
destroyed
and all form was in jail the whole time
like yeah access to it doesn't make
sense that's a little odd to me honestly
that's the only thing where it's like
well i don't you're gonna have to
explain that a little bit because when
did you have time to
to get anything i feel like an easier
explanation would have been like him
taking overhauls quirk or something
right then him doing this would make
sense sort of now it's like
how did you get access to rewind to do
this yeah well as we've learned with
dobby recently korokoshi is going to be
like well i've got a flashback for you
oh yeah
and we're just going to see him working
that that bullet and right before he was
captured well while we're on the topic
of derby i guess i'll start this thing
off with the predictions so
my first prediction was that derby
activates his true quirk which is a half
hot half coal quirk we've kind of seen
multiple times throughout the series
people don't understand their quirks a
lot of the time we saw it with toga
her quirk was so much different or
rather his potential was so much bigger
than she ever imagined and i feel like
it would be super ironic if this whole
time darby secretly inside him had
access to an ice quirk and he just
needed to activate it or he needed to be
triggered by him coming into contact
with uh with a bunch of ice because as
we saw you know him and shoto when they
were fighting shoto basically encased
his entire body and ice and then after
that that's when we see his glowing
chest so i feel like it would be awesome
if it did happen and i'm kind of hoping
it does the two brothers both having
half hot half gold i feel like that
would be really tragic
yeah in a sense right because dobby's
whole thing is like he he is a kind of a
misogynist let's be honest
just be completely honest he hates women
and i think he focused much too much on
endeavor growing up so if he did have
the eye side it would be mainly because
he never even thought about it right
like he was like uh my mom whatever i'm
all for the dad's stuff all for the fire
i'm gonna have this amazingly strong
fire and then like you have shoto who
like really wants to combine the two
sides of his lineage and the two sides
of his quirk and everything and that's
always been a very major focus for him
and then i feel like dobby is the
opposite where it's like i'm all for
endeavor side in this family so of
course i'm gonna have this ridiculously
crazy firepower but he might not have
even considered like hey maybe i can do
this ice like maybe i can actually do
that he's probably kind of ignored the
fact that that's possible yeah and even
when we see his flashback there was a
brief moment when his hair was half hot
half cold exactly like shoto like one
side was white one side was red and yeah
maybe he just never even thought about
it but it was there the whole time so
if he does wind up having
a nice quirk which personally i think it
would be better if he just winds up
exploding to be honest like nagant did
but if it is like
an awakening and he does get the ice
quirk then like what comes after that i
mean i i get that the fight would
probably continue but then like is it
ultimately leading to like
darby getting some kind of redemption
maybe not a full redemption but i feel
like he'd find a bit of peace like in
his in his head at least it would feel
good knowing that all along he had
everything he needed right like you were
perfect all along but i guess that's
where the tragedy comes in it's like all
this stuff happened
and it didn't have to and that's often
the story of a lot of villains in my
academia where it's like this really
didn't have to happen yeah i would be on
board with that
if he had like the last minute
realization but it was ultimately too
late yeah that would be cool
dad for one
dad for one that for one i do think
is possible but it's really easy to just
be like oh no he's not gonna copy star
wars or at all he's not gonna copy this
and dismiss it it's one of those things
that's a little too easy to dismiss i
mean every time i see this mentioned on
on social media i feel like most people
are against it just from the list
i feel like the most hated theory is
probably the back you go theory like
going back in time and then second is
probably this like i feel like they
switch every once in a while like
sometimes people are like no
no absolutely not we can't do the dad
for one thing but i've seen people kind
of turning around on the bakugou thing
when bakugo recently got that uh the the
damage to his face i saw a lot of people
coming out the woodwork like wait up
wait a minute hold on
hold on we might be back in action boys
so um
so there's also of course the whole
thing about yujiko
being in the very first chapter slash
episode which is not for no reason
definitely yeah so like what is that all
about
why is he the one to reveal to izuku
that he has no quirk and also i've
always thought about this since i first
saw
slash reddit when all might
says to i think he says it to wizuku
after they come out of their house or
something after he meets his mom for the
first time he's like yeah your mom looks
like nana i mean he doesn't say nana but
he says he basically says that
i mean her quirk is fairly similar she
looks very fairly similar she has a
similar hairstyle and let's be honest i
feel like horikoshi making her plus size
after the the initial kind of skinny
inko is specifically so that when all
might meets her he's not like you look
exactly actually like my man like with
that that's actually a little fishy i'm
gonna look into who you are whereas when
she's plus-sized it's like oh she kind
of reminds me of my master but it's a
little harder to make that clear
distinction of
you seeing the both of them together i
feel like if all might saw a younger
photo of inko he'd be like wait a minute
what is what's going on here
now also uh
it's said that izuku's father has
a fire breathing quirk right so
recently
we saw that all for one
does have some kind of fire quirk right
yeah there's a lot of like weird stuff
like that yeah the big i think the
biggest coincidence are good no no
please go i think the biggest
coincidence that's really hard to kind
of reconcile is we don't have the exact
timing for what year shigaraki got his
quirk is right but if you do like age
math it seems like he got his quirk the
same summer that deku was born
and that feels like a coincidence that
is very neat that doesn't need to be the
case so if you're an author you're gonna
do that for a reason
and that to me implies that all for one
looks at deku and he's like okay you
suck you are literally useless you're
not gonna have a quirk i can tell right
away somehow of all for one i'm gonna
now go and create the next meet in like
another way but shigaraki was possibly
quirkless as well right like tenko but
that's kind of hey you are at the age
where you have things to lose and you
have things that you care about and i
can create you
into a villain and also you're young
enough that i can realistically just
control you and tell you whatever i want
right who says i have to wait a couple
years for this kid to be of age then i'm
gonna have to kill anko and do all this
stuff
i'm just gonna go straight to the
granddaughter and grow or the grandson
and do it that way
okay well let's move on to the next
prediction so
the one i have down here i think all
might
might be able to coast his way to the
end of the series alive um now we all
remember like how his death used to be
such a big deal like especially during
season four i feel like we all used to
care about it so much but nowadays no
one even really talks about it yeah and
i feel like he's kind of faded into
irrelevance
there's not a lot of good ways to kill
all my right now honestly no no like
unless all for one goes out of his way
to find his command center break in and
just kill him but i just feel so forced
the only reasonable way that i thought
that all might could be taken down right
now is if shigeraki activates his decay
right like if that actually gets
activated and he decays the sky base but
that feels ah compared to how he like
other ways that he could have been taken
now and also aries with him so it's like
you know yeah
i believe is arie not with all my right
now or am i remembering i'm pretty sure
it was was it not during the previous
war arc when all mine and erie were
together and they were watching that's
probably what i remember then yeah i was
thinking that she was with him currently
so i'm like all right well even if decay
spreads through and like is going
through the base and is gonna kill all
might or something airy could like
activate rewind as an emergency last
second and then potentially at least
save both of them from being decayed but
eh right what then you just have all my
in a in a boss area unable to do
anything
because especially like even if he was
able to tap into one floor even just for
a second that's not going to do anything
against the main villains of the series
right at this current moment shigaraki
is basically invincible one punch from
one for all or one flick from one fall
it's not going to do anything we could
always go the corkless route right where
he mimics deku running to save bakugo in
the the first chapter and it's just oh
that would actually be good that's a
really good idea because when deku did
that moment in season one you know all
might was almost like paralyzing fear
watching it
yeah so that would be a nice parallel
actually i think you know what if he
does that i'll be happy with it if he
doesn't everyone thinks all might is
useless right now anyway you know him
proving hey i don't need a quirk to be
useful
like that is kind of one of the messages
here where it's like even you quirkless
people even you civilians you guys can
all be useful if you just act like
sometimes you just have to act to make
other people act and that's what that
did begin the series and i think all
might being the person who like was
taking care of everything before being
the person who makes people act and
makes people do things just by
more or less self-sacrificing himself in
a time where really
you're not that useful but i mean you
have to use every percent of usefulness
that you can get out that would actually
come full circle with all my two since
he started off uh quirkless yeah that's
probably one of the only decent ways to
get rid of all my and not have it feel
like you're just doing it because you
feel like you've set it up or the fandom
wants you to do it oh also before we go
forward uh erie the last time we see her
it's uh 3 42
she's with uh present mike when they're
like establishing
what their plan is going into the final
arc with like the troy stuff and
everything i mean other than that it's
kind of just like izuku saying goodbye
to her
uh
so she's just m.i.a at this point
realistically i'd probably send her away
but i feel like ua is so bad of managing
everyone that's there and then putting
them in dangerous situations so they
might just be like oh no we'll put her
at the bottom of the base where it's the
safest
yeah i wouldn't be surprised where's
this
he needs to get fired that guy like he
is right now he'd be probably great
against sugar rock right now get your
bulldozer and start knocking things over
and stuff do your calculations
all right since we're talking about him
do you think nezu's uh
gonna be
revealed to be a traitor i don't think
he's like a straight up trader in the
way that aoyama was i don't think he's
conscious of the fact that he is a
traitor he's like i'm like a manchurian
candidate exactly yeah because we
already know he's been experimented on
by humans you know recovery girl said it
pretty early on and we know that ujico
is a messed up guy so it's it works it
worked like him being the creation of
ujico especially when we consider that
all for one was bragging about how he
had so many friends in high places and
all this stuff so nezu is probably the
creation of ulf one and garaki but yeah
did you guys have any theories about
that i feel like to a certain extent
it's uh nezu has a weird place in the
series right because he seems like he
should have a little more importance
than he does
and there's the whole theory about rats
being the origin of quirks or something
like that or at least being related that
that uh shisaki presents us that they
completely cut out of the anime and then
you have rats on the logo of the
original uh liberation army right like
reed destro has a rat on the patch that
is the logo of the liberation army
before it becomes his face oh nice and
uchiko's been around for so long that
you could see he's already had one
popular theory on quirks right that
quirks the end of quirks is going to be
this crazy thing that's his theory so it
would make sense that he would have like
an opposite theory where it's like well
what's the origin and then that would
also be popular so maybe ujigo did make
nezu but like
where does that take nezu now you know
what i mean like where does that
importance lie and what he's gonna do at
the moment maybe it's just one of awful
ones like many options like backup plans
you know so maybe it might not come into
play maybe we could end the series and
we never see it in action but at the
same time if there's a situation where
it looks like the villain's defeated you
know you flip the nezu switch suddenly
he turns the table somehow
i mean because that does
explain what he is because it i'm pretty
sure it literally the exposition on him
literally says he's the only instance of
an animal ever getting a quirk we have
one individual
well
that's weird debatable i remember that i
i agree as well but i feel like we
shouldn't take that as bible because
it's vigilantes yeah but what i mean is
that it explains
how nezu got the quirk because all for
one slash yujiko gave it to him and also
it was said that he was experimented on
and that's why he hates humans or
whatever
which uh you know kind of seems sus
letting him be the principal but yeah
that's another story you know i hate
humans but i hate villains so much more
and also all right just before we go
forward i'm just saying he was a little
too happy
destroying cabinari and uh ashito oh he
was having a blast
well moving on to the next theory uh
pineapple you want to go next
let's see i have the i think flashbacks
of all my uh versus all for one and
maybe even the other final battles and
the vest space are gonna be happening
right like when deku's there to save
shigaraki or tenko from the all for one
vestige space i think that's when we're
finally gonna see some flashbacks to the
prime all might versus all for one fight
i've kind of given up on it to be honest
because i just i've wanted it so bad for
so long and then it just
never transpired so if it does so if we
do ultimately wind up seeing it uh
through the sequence that you're talking
about i think that would just be
incredible like and then we get to see
like the other fights as well too oh man
that would be incredible as fans we
deserve to see those fights not to get
into the entitlement i guess since but
also it's been set up right so like it's
been set up to a certain extent that the
vestige space is good at doing
flashbacks and showing you like
literally what happened in the past
and
i i just think that's the best place in
a natural sense to show you the previous
one for all battles instead of like
deku reflecting or something and seeing
it that way and then having an
interruption in this arc that we're in
where it's like okay well now we have to
do 10 chapters 15 chapters like a mini
arc you say 15 chapters that that raises
another question so horakoshi said what
at like jump fest or whatever 2021 that
the series only had like a year left
that kind of seems unlikely at this
point and i'm not just saying it as like
you know a copium huffing
and mha fan on twitter that's like yeah
this series ain't ending in a year or
we've got like another three years left
i'm just saying like if it does end in
like the next four months or whatever
that would be odd because there's so
much
that still needs to happen yeah not even
like speculating about oh well this
character needs to do that just
basically what's been set up for the
rest of the arc that we've actually seen
that is going to happen i mean deku
hasn't even arrived at shigaraki yet it
is yeah it's been going on for a while
and that still hasn't happened so yeah
there's a lot to wrap up still and he
clearly has to have the longest fight i
mean if bakugo and everyone is going to
get seven chapters dedicated to fighting
shiguraki you would assume deku's versus
shigaraki is gonna be like 10 chapters
and be
big in scale and everything or how long
was the star in stripe in shigaraki
fight it has to at least be longer than
that you would assume uh it was like
3 30 to 3 34 i think okay oh so shorter
than i thought
yeah i just assume it's gonna be a
little longer than most of the fights in
the series because it is the final
battle but i mean consider that right
like we have that fight still then we
have the dobby situation if something's
gonna happen there we haven't really
delved into the kirimina area where like
machia is present underground and
they're fighting uh the person who took
out midnight then the whole thing of
toga like there is still a lot to cover
even just finishing the battles that are
taking place
one of the things that i was worried
about with the rest of this series
happening is that the rest of class 1a
doesn't get the development that they
deserve i feel like most of it is done
honestly
like i agree that they haven't gotten
the level that they deserve but i feel
like we're kind of in the part where
he's like okay i've done what i've done
what i could do i'll try to develop
everyone as much as i can through their
final battles like hiroshima and mina
being in the same place as maki is
definitely to call back to you know
their early i was afraid of making a
thing maybe they'll do something i don't
think they're gonna just outright defeat
them together because how realistically
the two of you do that
but i definitely think those kind of
things or we're calling back to all the
moments where i tried to develop these
uh these characters but people like sato
aren't really going to get much i would
imagine like oh hell no
i think it could be wasted pages at this
point yeah no give me the ones you set
up already don't try to now force in a
minetta backstory that i don't eat
you need a manet redemption i mean if
manipulative stops machia you know
that'll be the coolest thing ever
just suffocates him with like the great
balls these balls
so go if we're talking about the final
aspects of the series or going into the
future or whatnot uh i do think it's a
possibility that what endeavors saw was
factual because it was a little too
nuanced to just be like oh this is what
i think is going to happen because you
know izuku's cape had like an additional
layer to it hiroshima has a whole
different outfit
yeah and of course shoto's haircut
but
also what i'm thinking is that like
something has to happen with quirks
because like as far as i know and and my
quirk science that i have a degree in uh
the the quirk singularity is like a real
thing yeah and sugar rocky's whole thing
is kind of like a
showing us hey things can get this bad
where you don't even technically have a
quirk and you're still able to do these
horrific things
so like and the fact that horukoshi has
talked about it so much i mean he's
never like
i don't know dedicated a chapter to like
hey guys this is like a serious thing
and we we need to address this he just
you know every now and then it'll be
like hey quirk singularity it's like
this i don't even think izuku ever
really acknowledges it within the actual
manga as far as i know it's been
mentioned to him at most yeah when he
talks about it in the uh
world heroes mission movie that came out
um last year
uh the
the bad guy fleck turn is his name um he
he says he's basically says the quirk
singularity to izuku and izuku's like
yeah but that's just like a theory
or something like that it's not weird
right because like i feel like at that
point he's already had the dream where
the first user was like yeah no we're in
singularity
it's happening
we're past singularity
so i'm thinking that like how is that
going to be addressed uh in the final
portion of the series because
realistically
all quirks have to die
not people but just quirks have to go
away in order for humanity to survive i
feel like it's a lose-lose situation
because if you don't address the
singularity it's like wow okay everyone
goes on they become these famous heroes
but at some point in the future the
singularity is going to destroy everyone
yeah right but then if you do address it
okay that means everyone's quotes get
taken away no one's a hero their world
is just going back it's gone back to the
boring world that we live in
but um who wants to do the final
prediction for the for the video i feel
like it should be you me oh uh let's see
what have i got here uh
so this one is shigaraki will steal a
student's quirk so
recently we've been seeing shiguraki
with his one million hands and at no
point has he ever been able to actually
use it for its true purpose because you
know as we know off one the whole way
you steal quirks is by using a hand to
take it and he's not been able to do
that because of monomer so i was kind of
thinking that maybe once monomer
eventually blinks and it will happen
eventually yes once that happens you
know shigeru just has so many hands one
of those hands could just steal a quirk
i'm thinking maybe from kaminari just
one of those side characters where it
would be pretty sad but it wouldn't be
the end of the world
i have a funny answer and a serious
answer i think the funniest answer would
be miriam
no
no no no no take that one back again
this time you're not getting it back
buddy but also imagine the danger level
and how much that would rise if suddenly
[ __ ] rocky can fade
jesus christ but then again you know it
was specifically shown that muriel had
to train his butt off to like oh that's
valid
so so shigaraki just falls through the
earth immediately how does all for one
work when you take a quirk does it give
you information on how to use the quirk
in a similar way to like monomers quirk
or are you literally just like oh no i
actually have to learn how to use this
well i mean he did say he didn't want to
take best geniuses quirk because it took
so much training that's valid oh yeah he
wouldn't do that pretty much like he
wouldn't try to train and use your quirk
so it's not a good one for him
if you guys could pick one student okay
so pineapple you've already said mario
yeah i think that would be the funniest
and probably the most dangerous for him
to take honestly um
man
you got a lot of choices like sugar rush
you know
go nuts
yeah
that's my choice
it's gonna take a sugar rush santos
quirk i realize this is the most broken
quirk here
he just has like bags and bags of like
tons of sugar just
that he brought with him for some reason
just in preparation and he just goes
insane
just before you end the video i went
through the last collab we did last year
and i thought i'd mention a couple of
the ones that we got right um pineapple
said that the ua traitor will be
revealed while everyone and their
parents were at ua which was hey guys
i don't know how you said it so
accurately i went so hard of the aoyama
theory that's what it is i was just
committed i was like people think i'm
crazy i'm doing it now we're gonna
commit and i'm gonna turn my brain on as
hard as i can
that was your baby you you held that in
your uterus for a long time
it was time to give birth it was
spectacular 100 million percent people
were like ah this isn't that baby's not
gonna be born when you think it is and
it's like no i know i know my son trust
me
[Laughter]
and um shonen said that uh shinzo will
replace izuku which kind of happened
like he's joined the class but he's not
replaced him uh because i guess izuku is
still around but uh yeah it's mostly
true i'm gonna give you that one still
speaking of him where what the hell is
he doing
uh
which battlefield is he on that's right
i don't know
if shinzo was a shot before azuki does i
feel like he'd be the one to he'd be the
only person who could take shiguraki
down because physical quirks aren't
working against this guy they're not
working against him so
mental quirks like shinzo's i think
would be probably the only course of
action if uzuku isn't there honestly i
think that has to happen just off of isa
being there you know and like having his
student be helpful and since shinto's
whole issue is i can't help people with
my quirk i've been told my entire life
i'm like a villain and i can't help
anyone with my quirk and it's not going
to be useful how about saving everyone
at ua against the biggest villain in the
series using your quirk so as far as i
know we don't know where shinso is i
don't think the last time we saw him do
something
was 344 he was making
uh aoyama's parents talk hopefully
that's not his only role imagine
i'm going to give him a telephone real
quick
yeah well anyway guys thank you for both
for coming on the channel and uh to
everyone watching be sure to check out
their channels if you haven't already
i'm pretty sure most people watching
know of both of you but if you're not
subscribed already then check out the
link in the description and yeah sub to
their channels thank you so much thank
you as always